I learned about context engineering for
you. So, let me now save you the hours
you have to spend scrolling through X
and Reddit trying to understand what is
context engineering. The outline of
today's video is that I'm going to first
explain what is context engineering, why
it came about, and what it's relevant
for. Then, we'll talk about how to do
context engineering, and finally some
examples to make it all concrete. As per
usual, it's not enough for me just to
talk about stuff. So, there will be
little assessments throughout this
video. So, please pay attention. And if
you can answer these questions, then
congratulations. you have now been
educated on context engineering. So
without further ado, let's go. A portion
of this video is sponsored by Augment
Code. All right, let's first define
context engineering. Context engineering
is designing and building dynamic
systems that give an LM the right info
in the right format at the right time to
accomplish a task. In other words,
you're packing the context window, which
is the input area of a large language
model just right. All right, now that
we've defined the term, the first point
I want to make is that context
engineering is only relevant to people
who are making LLM apps, including
things like AI agents. You may have
already heard or read online that
context engineering is the new prompt
engineering. That is true, but it
doesn't mean that like prompt
engineering is dead. For example, if you
just want to chat with a chatbot, like
chat GBT about the kind of running shoes
that you should choose for your feet.
You know, you're having a back and forth
conversation talking about the different
cushioning types, uh, certain price
ranges, how different outfits match up
for your running outfits. All of that is
prompting. That's still prompt
engineering, and it's still completely
relevant in those scenarios. Context
engineering only becomes relevant when
you're building AI applications like AI
agents. Because unlike that chatbi
conversation where you're just going
back and forth, when you're building
something like an AI agent, you can't
iteratively keep talking to the agent
until it gets the answer correct. You
need to give it a set of instructions
that encompasses all the actions it has
to take and all the different scenarios
that it's going to encounter. For
example, if you're building a customer
service AI agent for your online store,
that agent needs to be equipped with the
ability to handle all sorts of inquiries
like billing problems, refund issues,
login issues, searching up terms and
conditions because people can't read,
people asking it stupid irrelevant
questions, probably also people yelling
at it and abusing it unfortunately, and
be able to escalate to a human when
necessary. And to be able to give it all
the instructions and resources and
everything that it needs in order to
accomplish these tasks, your prompts
become larger and larger and more and
more complex. At some point they even
start to resemble code with XML tags and
markdown. As you can see this is really
really different than just prompting and
having a conversation with chatbt which
is why people came up with the term
context engineering. So yeah that's
pretty much it. Context engineering
isn't some new technique that's
completely coming out of the blue. It
really is the progression of prompt
engineering in the very specific cases
of crafting complex prompts for building
AI applications. As Andre Kaparthy
explains the LM is the CPU and the
context window is the RAM. Make sense?
I'm going to put on screen now a little
assessment. Please write in the comments
your answer. All right, let's now dive
deeper into what context engineering
actually looks like when we're building
an AI agent. First, to make sure we're
all on the same page, the definition of
an AI agent is a software system that
uses AI to pursue goals and complete
tasks on behalf of users. For example, a
customer service AI agent that answers
customer service queries. A sales
assistant AI agent that's able to
qualify leads and follow up with people.
A coding agent that can help you to
code. There are lots and lots of
different types of AI agents. However,
regardless of what types of AI agents
there are, there are six components
which are essential building blocks that
make up an AI agent. The first component
is model. Every AI agent needs to have
an AI model. It can be open GPT models,
it can be claude, it can be Gemini, it
can be smaller models, it can be larger
models, it can be open source models,
whatever fits. The second component is
tools. Tools allow agents to be able to
interact with external systems. For
example, a personal assistant agent
needs to be able to have a tool that
allows it to access your Google calendar
to be able to book appointments for you.
Next up is knowledge and memory. Most
agents need a way to store and retrieve
information. For example, if you have a
therapy AI agent and you're having
conversations with it, you need it to
have memory so that it's able to
remember what has been said in previous
conversations. If you have a legal AI
agent that's meant to screen through
some very specific cases, you need to
give it the knowledge base of those
specific cases that you want it to work
on. Then there's audio and speech.
Equipping your AI agent with the ability
for audio and speech will allow it to be
a lot more natural and easier to
interact with. Every AI agent also needs
to have guardrails which are safety
mechanisms to ensure proper behavior.
You don't want your customer service AI
agent to swear back at your users
probably. And finally, there is
orchestration. These are systems that
allow you to deploy your AI agent,
monitor them, and improve them over
time. You don't want to just release
your AI agent into the wild and just run
away. Got to keep track of what it's
doing. The analogy that I like to make
is that these six components of AI
agents is sort of like a burger. Like in
order for a burger to be considered a
burger, it needs to have a bun, a patty,
vegetables, and condiments. You can have
different types of buns like whole
wheat, whites, even lettuce buns and
different types of patties, like
different types of meats. But you do
need to have these different components
to be able to be called a burger. Same
with AI agents. You can have different
types within these components, but you
do need to have these components to be
considered an AI agent. Now, continuing
this analogy, imagine that you are an
alien and you don't understand how these
burger thingies work. So, whoever is
telling you to make a burger probably
needs to also provide an instructions
manual telling you that the bun goes on
either side. Then you're supposed to put
in the vegetables, the condiments, and
the patty in the middle. And that's how
you would know how to assemble your
burger. It's the same thing for AI
agents. You can have all of these
different components of these AI agents,
but you need to have an instruction
manual for how all these things fit
together. And that is where the context
engineer comes in. You're coming up with
that prompt that exactly details how
everything is working together, what the
tools are, how to use them, how to
access memory, what's in the knowledge
base, when to use speech and audio
functionalities, etc., etc. The
resulting prompt is going to be the
instructions manual for your AI agent to
be able to use all the things that it's
equipped with. It is really important to
get this prompt right, and people spend
a lot of time context engineering until
they get that perfect prompt. Time for
the next little assessment. Please
answer the questions on screen and put
your answers in the comments. As we've
already talked about, context
engineering goes handinhand with
building AI applications. And when it
comes to building AI applications that
are meant to be more than just proof of
concepts or demos, pure vibe coding just
isn't enough. That is where Augment code
comes in. It's built for real
engineering work, including debugging,
writing tests, refactoring, and
navigating complex systems. Augment's
context engine feeds Claude Sonnet for
exactly what it needs for your codebase.
There's no need for guessing, model
picking, or forks. Just a deeply
integrated assistant that helps you
ship. You can even launch cloud agents
to refactor or fix tests even when your
laptop is closed. It runs in your IDE
including VS Code, Jet Brains, Vim, and
Cursor. They also take security very,
very seriously. Augment is ISO and SOCK
2 certified, and there's no training on
customer code. You can try it off for
free for 14 days at this link over here,
also linked in description. Thank you so
much Augment Code for sponsoring this
portion of the video. Now, back to the
video. Okay, I'm going to show you now a
full example of a context engineered
prompt for an AI agent. Specifically,
this is a prompt for an AI research
assistant that I made for myself in
order to keep up with all the AI trends.
The general structure of the system
prompt is that I have these six
different components. It helps um
structure the prompt in a way that is
easier to follow. So, under role, you're
an AI research assistant focused on
identifying and summarizing recent
trends in AI from multiple source types.
Your job is to break down a user's query
into actionable subtasks and return the
most relevant insights based on
engagement and authority. Under task, so
the thing that we actually want the AI
agent to do, we have given a research
query delimited by the XML tags user
query and end tag user query. So this is
um XML tags. It's also a way to
structure the information so it's more
clear for the AI to be able to process.
Do the following. Step one is to extract
up to 10 diverse high priority subtasks
each targeting a different angle or
source type. Step two is to prioritize
by engagement such as views, likes,
repost, and citations as well as
authority of source such as publication,
reputation, and domain expertise. Step
three is to generate a JSON output for
each subtask in the format below. And
step four is to calculate the correct
start date and end date in UTC ISO
format based on the specified time
period. And step five is to summarize
all findings into a single concise trend
summary approximately 300 words max. As
you can see, it is very very structured
and detailed going step by step saying
that you need to extract up to 10
different subtasks like 10 different
types of sources regarding a specific
topic from the user. You need to
prioritize it. Uh generate certain
specified JSON outputs like a type of
output and make sure that the time
periods are in the correct time period
that the user specifies and then go on
to actually summarize all the findings.
The input is within the XML tags which
is user query. Uh it says insert search
query here. This is where the user would
input whatever it is that they want to
search. So for the output of this agent,
you have you will output up to 10
subtasks in this exact format and this
is a JSON format that we very clearly
stated. So every single subtask which is
a source it needs to be exactly in this
format has the ID the query specifies
subquery related to one aspect of the
main topic. The source type it can be
news, it can be from X, it can be from
Reddit, LinkedIn, newsletter, academic
or specialized. The time period when
that resource came out it can be between
1 day to 10 days. Domain focus is a
technology science or health priority
determining how important this source is
from highest of one to lowest of 10 and
the start date and the end date in this
specific format. Under output, it says
that you will output up to 10 subtasks
in this exact format. So we can see here
that this is JSON format and we're
specifying all of the different
variables that need to be there. Then
after performing all subtasks, write a
final output summarizing the key recent
trends, including limiting to 300 words
using bullet points or short paragraphs.
Only include new relevant high signal
developments and avoiding fluff
background or personal commentary. Then
there's constraints. Focus on capturing
the main point succinctly. Complete
sentences and perfect grammar are
unnecessary. Ignore fluff background
information and commentary. Do not
include your own analysis or opinions.
Then finally, we have capabilities and
reminders. We're telling it what are the
different tools and knowledge bases that
it has access to and giving it very
specific reminders so it doesn't go off
track. You have access to the web search
tool to find and retrieve recent news
articles relevant to the search term.
You must be deeply aware of the current
date to ensure the relevance of news
summarizing only information published
within the past 10 days. So this is
example of a system prompt for a single
research assistant AI agent. So and this
is actually considered a very very
simple prompt. I also contain everything
within that singular AI agent. When
actually like normally when I do
something like this, I would generally
split it into multi- aent systems where
you would have one agent that searches
up all the different sources and you
have another agent that would actually
go and summarize everything for you. But
even just for illustration purposes, I
hope you can see that how complex this
context engineering can get. And it's
going to go and gather information,
gather news from different newsletters
as well as Reddit. Then it would
aggregate all of that information
together and ultimately come up with a
summary that it's going to send to me on
WhatsApp. And in this case, I
implemented this AI agent using NAT. You
can of course implement this using a
variety of other tools as well. Like in
our AI agents boot camp, we teach people
to implement no code agents using NAT.
And for people who want to use code, uh
we would generally teach them how to use
like something like OpenAI's agents SDK.
But it doesn't actually matter whatever
it is that you use to implement these
prompts. Um they are applicable across
different agentic systems. So before I
end this video, I do want to share with
you guys two additional resources which
I think are excellent if you really want
to dive deeper into context engineering
and how it is that you can go about uh
creating these multi-agent systems and
getting the results from it. The first
one is a blog post from cognition and
they share two fundamental principles
for context engineering specific for
multi- aent frameworks. The first one is
to always share context between your
agents. And the second is that actions
carry implicit decisions. And whenever
you have a decision point, you need to
be very very careful of this in your
architecture and in your context
engineering as well. Highly recommend
that you check out this blog post. The
second article is from Langchain where
they showcase this really great
framework that breaks down common
strategies that people use when context
engineering. The first one is writing
context. How it is that you can allow
your large language model to write down
information surrounding a task so it's
able to save it and use it for later.
The second is selecting context. How it
is that you can pull information from
external sources to help your agent
perform a task. The third is compressing
context. When there is a lot of
information that you're trying to give
in large language model, there are
techniques that you can do in order to
help compress that information in a more
compact way. And the fourth is isolating
context. How to split context in between
different environments and different
places. I'm not going to go into more
details about this to keep this video
relatively succinct, but you do want to
dig deeper into techniques for context
engineering so you can build better AI
apps like AI agents. Highly recommend
that you check out these resources. All
right, that is everything that I have
for you today. So, here is the final
little assessment. Please write your
answers in the comments below. Thank you
so much for watching until the end of
this video and I will see you guys in
the next video or live stream.